hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to update
3.0 so i've left the 2.0 series this is
update 3.0 and welcome you got a few
things to mention to you guys and uh the
first thing of all those things is that
i'm on summer vacation right now i'm
officially done with sophomore year of
high school and i have about well about
two months of summer vacation that i get
to
actually make videos and not have to do
homework in between um so it's gonna be
really awesome that i get to do that so
yeah me so i'm just making this update
video to answer a number of popular
questions that i've been getting so it's
kind of like an inbox video but not
quite uh but those will be those will be
in the future uh anyway uh the first
thing is that when am i going to be
applying for a youtube partnership or
when am i going to make partner
actually plan on applying for a youtube
partnership this week and actually
making a kind of a comedic sort of video
about it uh a tutorial on applying for a
youtube partnership so actually going to
the website filling out the application
and i'll definitely get to you guys with
the results of that application uh in
the future uh but yeah i'm gonna make a
tutorial on how to apply for a youtube
partnership i'm going to apply this week
and uh hopefully i'll get in and i'll be
able to have an awesome banner and do
cool stuff with that the next part of
this video is a question for you guys
the viewers the subscribers the people
who actually did dictate what i put on
my channel uh i've been doing like a
video a day for about two months now
unless uh for some strange reason there
was an exception but i'm doing pretty
much a video a day and i'm getting like
300 to 400 500 views per video depending
on how popular it is
and i did a few experiments updating
uploading a video once every other day
and i got a few different results so i
want to know what your guys opinion what
your opinion is should i upload a video
once a day
or once every other day what do you
think during the summer i think more
people will be able to watch youtube
videos more people will be able to
comment rate and subscribe and actually
interact in the community so again you
pick once a day or twice a day leave a
comment below if you have any other
strong opinions about whether or not i
should upload a video every day or every
other day let me know or anything else
maybe every three days or twice a day i
don't know you guys can pick you guys
decide the next point of this update
video is to let you guys know what's
coming up in the future and um you guys
seen me unbox a lot of things uh but i
haven't actually reviewed them yet i'm
actually filming a bunch of reviews
today uh for products that i've received
uh from ifrogs from griffin from audeo
from cena from a lot of different
companies and a lot of different cool
stuff that i think you guys will like
and i'm going to be mixing that with
hardware and software so again if i do
that video a day thing it's going to be
hardware software hardware software
switching back and forth every day so
that's why i need your opinion on that
now i know a lot of you guys subscribed
for the hardware and a lot of you guys
subscribe for the software but i'm going
to be putting it all on the same channel
so you get to decide uh with the one
video a day thing or a video every other
day thing uh what you want to see more
of do you want to see more hardware or
do you want to see more software i'm
guessing you want to see more software
which is why i'm going to be uh looking
more into that and doing more research
around that
but yeah i'm basically going to be going
over
basically going over more software and
hardware in the next few weeks of my
summer vacation so that's going to be
awesome another exciting thing is that i
have a list of the videos that are
coming up on my channel page so if you
click on my logo or just right click it
and open a new tab
if you look on the left hand side of my
channel page you'll see a list of the
videos i have upcoming and one of those
videos is a massive giveaway video yes a
huge mkbhd giveaway you're not going to
want to miss out on this this is going
to be a great giveaway it's going to be
pretty much
eight or nine or ten a lot of products
that i've received and a lot of products
that i've had for a while that i just
want to give back to you guys you guys
have been kind enough to rate and
comment my videos uh have been
appreciative of the tech channel the
week series the playlist i've been doing
so i'm going to give it back to you guys
uh with a giveaway this summer possibly
a partnership giveaway or a 15 a 2 000
subscriber giveaway i don't know
whatever whatever comes first uh but
that's in the video series of videos to
come if you go ahead and click on my
channel logo but really other than that
guys it's going to be a bunch of product
reviews a bunch of new youtube features
and a bunch of new software videos uh
that i'm going to be putting out in the
future and i just hope you guys enjoy
them so thank you to the 1500
subscribers that i just got about three
days ago which is really cool i've been
tweeting about it and speaking of
twitter
follow me on twitter yeah pretty good
shout out right there anyway that is
basically it for you guys i hope you
enjoyed this update 3.0 video if you
haven't already if you're watching me
for the first time go ahead and click
that golden button over there that says
subscribe you're going to want to do
that a lot of cool tech stuff comes out
of this channel i get ideas from people
all over youtube and it's really cool
that i get to do these videos for you
guys to watch
so uh anyway thanks for watching this
update 3.0 from mkbhd
um and uh wish me luck in applying for
youtube partnership and that is
basically it thanks for watching guys
peace